Speaker 1: but also have to
talk about one more thing here.
Biden's done some good. OK, we can't just sit
here and say, Oh, build back better is dead.
And Biden's not doing anything for young young
voters, whatever it is, because Biden has done
one thing that is truly phenomenal, that he is
unfortunately not getting enough credit for.
And I do believe in giving credit where credit's
due, and that is appointing federal judges
since the Senate is out for the year now. Biden,
in his first year in office, has gotten confirmed
40 federal judges to lifetime appointments here in
the United States. That is more than any president
in their first year in office since Ronald
Reagan. And by the way, it's more than double
what Donald Trump got in his first year in office
when he had the Senate under Republican control.
That's pretty remarkable. But it's not
just the number that's remarkable here,
because anybody can appoint judges, right,
get the numbers up, you look good. But the
fact? Is that a lot of these
people that Biden has picked
are either coming from a background as public
defenders or from plaintiff's law firms?
And that's a huge difference from what we even saw
with President Obama. President Obama picked a lot
of people, obviously with the liberal credentials,
but they came from these corporate defense law
firms. And that's why even his administration saw
some of their rules struck down by the very judges
he put in place for a lifetime because they
benefited consumers rather than corporations.
These judges, depending on their background, do
obviously have a bias. You cannot say that they
don't. They're not supposed to, but they
do. And so picking people who spent their
careers representing injured people, injured
consumers, and now they get to be the judges.
That is a massive step forward that is huge
for this country. And again, typically this is
not something that we see even from Democratic
presidents. So Joe Biden, President Joe Biden
deserves a ton of credit for what he is doing with
these federal judges so far in year one, that has
absolutely been the brightest spot of this entire
administration. I am Farron Cousins of sitting in
for David Pakman. Follow me on Twitter at fair
and Balanced. It will be right back with more.